[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen wenn der Druck steigt
bleibt der Kanzler erst recht still wenn
ihn alle in einer Richtung drängen dann
hält er gerade doppelt dagegen das ist
so ein Deutungsmuster das immer wieder
bemüht wird um etwas zu erklären dass
der Kanzler selbst leider kaum erklärt
nämlich die deutsche Haltung zu
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine es war
so bei den Schützenpanzern es war so bei
den flugabwehrsystemen es ist jetzt so
beim Kampfpanzer kommt ein okay aus
Berlin kommt es nicht
die Ukraine fleht die Verbündeten
schütteln zunehmend ihre Köpfe aus der
eigenen Koalition attackieren sie ihn
und Olaf Scholz bleibt ruhig würde er
jetzt sagen Olaf Scholz schadet
Deutschlands ansehen sagen andere einer
der sich von der Öffentlichkeit nicht
treiben lassen will wird zum getriebenen
Thomas Reichert
diese Lieferung jedenfalls klappt heute
früh schickt die Bundeswehr Patriot
Flugabwehr Staffeln aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in den Südosten
Polens 60 km entfernt von der Grenze zu
Ukraine sollen sie dort den
nato-luftraum Schützen in Polen aber
wünschen sie sich noch etwas ganz
anderes die Freigabe von Leopard 2
Panzern aus Polen für die Ukraine bei
den Deutschland hergestellt braucht es
dafür die Erlaubnis aus Berlin aber
polen will auf jeden Fall liefern in
einer kleinen Koalition mit anderen
Ländern
selbst wenn wir diese Erlaubnis nicht
bekommen würden und die Deutschen nicht
in dieser Koalition wären werden wir
trotzdem unsere Panzer zusammen mit
anderen an die Ukraine übergeben
na Ukraine es ist nicht das erste Mal
das Polen auf diese Weise Druck ausübt
und es ist nicht das erste Mal dass
Deutschlands offizielle Antworten nur so
viel sagt zunächst sei der Dienstweg
einzuhalten wenn ein solcher Antrag in
Deutschland gestellt würde was zur
Stunde noch nicht der Fall ist dann gibt
es dafür eingespielte Verfahren in dem
ein solches ein solcher Anfrage
beantwortet wird und dann die halten wir
uns alle
polen will den Antrag nun Stellen
derweil erhöhen andere Länder in Brüssel
den Druck auf Deutschland
Germany Deutschland ist der Motor
Europas der größte Partner in der
Europäischen Union daraus ergibt sich
auch eine besondere Verantwortung
wir fordern Deutschland erneut auf
Leopard zweikampfpanzer an die Ukraine
zu liefern ich denke dass dies sehr
wichtig ist
die deutsche Außenministerin will heute
in Brüssel keine Nachfragen zu
Panzerlieferungen beantworten vielen
Dank dafür erhöht der grüne
Parteivorsitzende den Druck wer
schützenpanzerlieferer könne bei
Kampfpanzer nicht nein sagen weiß nicht
warum Schützenpanzer nicht eskalativ
sind aber Kampfpanzer schon deshalb ist
es umso notwendiger dass das
letztendlich Klarheit geht und zwar so
schnell wie möglich unsere Partner
starten allen voran die Menschen in der
Ukraine haben das verdient so bringt die
Leopard 2 Frage die Ampel in eine
schwere Krise der SPD Parteivorsitzende
präsentiert heute in Positionspapier das
seine stärkere Führung Deutschland
verspricht in der panzerfrage aber teilt
der unverblümt aus z.B gegen der Kritik
aus der FDP wenn aus meiner Partei
andauernd solche Querschüsse kommen
würde ich mit den entsprechenden Leuten
mal reden es wirft ja auch kein gutes
Licht auf die eigene parteiführungwende
andauernd welche so
unterwegs sind aber ich will ja gar
nicht Konflikte weiter anheizen Satz und
macht genau das die FDP selbst ist heute
bemüht und die Eskalation vielleicht in
den wissen dass Deutschland am Ende eine
Lieferung Polens nur schwer untersagen
kann wir sind keine
Opposition in der Koalition entscheiden
ist dass wir am Ende des Tages
gemeinsame Lösungen hinbekommen dass die
Ampel das Scholz sich entscheidet darauf
warten im Moment viele in Deutschland
der Ukraine und in Europa
ist Luxemburgs Außenminister er war
heute bei dem Außenminister treffen auch
mit dabei Herr Asselborn schönen guten
Abend
guten Abend wissen Sie was Ihr
sozialdemokratischer Parteifreund Olaf
Scholz vorhat mit den Leopard 2 Panzern
also es war immer nicht so einfach große
deutsche Politiker zu verstehen auch
Bundeskanzler das Phase oder sich so
aber ich glaube dass wir was ich
jedenfalls Europäer dass wir eine klare
Linie haben seit einem Jahr jetzt seit
dem 24 februar und dass diese Linie ist
dass wir Sanktionen entschieden haben
sehr schnell sehr massiv um Putin
einzuschränken das ist auch das ganze
die diplomatische Mittel was wir haben
was nicht militärisches und das zweite
ist dass wir angefangen haben in einer
gewissen Zeit auch Waffen zu liefern die
keine damit sich wehren kann wir kommen
jetzt glaube ich ganz schnell an einen
Punkt wo Russland einsehen muss und
einsehen wird dass es diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen kann und das hängt natürlich
auch davon ab wie wir im Westen auch in
Europa uns aufstellen
eine entscheidender Punkt sagen sie der
neue deutsche Verteidigungsminister sagt
es gibt für Waffenlieferungen guter
Argumente es gibt aber auch
gegenwaffenlieferungen gute Argumente
welche guten Argumente dagegen haben Sie
denn von den deutschen gehört
also ich bin nur ein entscheidender
Luxemburger ich kann mich ja nicht in
die deutsche Innenpolitik einigen ich
will sagen dass dieser Zeitpunkt so
glaube ich zu verstehen kommen kann wenn
Russland diese
Frühjahrsoffensive startet wenn die
Frühjahrsoffensive gestartet werden und
das da gehe ich von davon aus dass auch
der deutsche Bundeskanzler das im Kopf
hat dass wir dann bereit sein müssen in
Europa im Westen um eben dann
militärisches Zeug und das sind ja das
sind Panzer zur Verfügung stellen damit
die Ukraine nicht überrollt wird damit
noch mehr hunderttausende Menschen in
der Ukraine sterben und das Russland
einsieht dass dieser Krieg nichts
gewinnen ist ich glaube wir wissen ja
auch dass das nicht 20 lückler und 20
Abrahams und 20 das muss schon eine
große Zahl sein man spricht von 300
Panzern die dann zur Verfügung stehen
müssen und da können wir schauen uns
umschauen es gibt nur eine machte das
ist eben oder ein Name das ist dann der
Leopard der auch so massive in Europa
präsent ist und ich bin überzeugt dass
der deutsche Kanzler ja bis jetzt soweit
ich im deutschen Sprache mächtig bin
nicht nein gesagt hat er hat jetzt noch
nicht ja gesagt er war nicht nein gesagt
er ist ein intelligenter Mensch und ich
bin davon überzeugt dass der Zeitpunkt
kommt wo auch dann stufenweise diese
Entscheidung dann wachsen wird das ist
und stufenweise ein Jahr kommen ein
stufenweise ein Jahr kommt aus Berlin
sie sagen also quasi es ist mehr oder
weniger nur noch eine Frage der Zeit wie
isoliert ist denn Deutschland in Europa
aktuell aus ihrer Wahrnehmung mit der
derzeitigen nicht ja aber auch nicht
nein Haltung
ich wollte sagen das ist die eigene nach
der Demokratie dass in so
schwerwiegenden Fragen der Verantwortung
dass man hier abfällt und ich glaube
nicht ich glaube dass sie da in
Deutschland einen kleinen Fehler machen
dass jetzt jeder aussätzlich ist auf
Deutschland oder auf den Bundeskanzler
ich habe mir heute erlaubt im Rat zu
sagen es ist nicht der Feind ist nicht
Bundeskanzler Scholz der Feind heißt
Putin und darauf sollten wir uns
konzentrieren wirklich man muss doch
abwägen können in einer Demokratie dass
man zu einem Ziel kommt und dieses Ziel
wird da bin ich fest davon überzeugt
auch von Deutschland Kanzler
wahrgenommen und das Ziel heißt dass man
sich aufstellt so aufstellt dass die
Ukraine bei einem großen Angriff der
kommt im Frühjahr Mittel hat um sich
dagegen zu werden dann frage ich noch
mal andersrum denn Deutschland ist ja
aktuell abgesehen von USA und
Großbritannien tatsächlich bereits der
größte Waffenlieferant der Ukraine das
wird immer so ein bisschen ausgeblendet
in Europa bei manchen anderen Staaten
hat man den Eindruck verstecken sich da
auch andere Zögerer jetzt gerade hinter
der deutschen Haltung
ich habe noch einmal sich dein
demokratischer Prozess der stattfinden
muss ich kann Ihnen nur sagen dass um
den Tisch von 27 Deutschland nicht so
isoliert ist wie Sie vielleicht das in
der deutschen Medien darstellen das ist
nicht so ich will jetzt keine anderen
Länder nennen aber es sind auch andere
Länder große Länder Grenzländer die
zögern diesen Schritt zu machen der
Schritt muss
zum Beispiel Spanien zum Beispiel das
mal Leopard Panzer angeboten hatte und
jetzt wieder zurückgezogen hat
frankreich hat keine
keine Anzahl von Panzern in dieser Größe
die haben ja die Challenges das sind
kleinere
kleinere Maschinen stellen sie zur
Verfügung aber
man muss wissen 300 Panzer müssen ja
synchron sein die dieselbe Musik
Munition gebrauchen und es kann nicht 45
verschiedene Sorten sein
das ist eben der Leopard sie sagen
frankreich hat nicht genug Panzer in
dieser Größenordnung das Problem scheint
allerdings zu sein in Deutschland hat
auch nicht genug Panzer in dieser
Größenordnung sie haben vorhin in
unserem Gespräch gesagt 300 Panzer
bräuchte die Ukraine es gibt jetzt
Berichte nach denen es in Deutschland
für die Bundeswehr aktuell überhaupt nur
200 gibt die angemessen fahren können
und die Bundeswehr maximal 19 abgeben
könnte
also darum hat ja glaube ich der neue
vertragsminister
pistorisch gesagt er will genau sehen
was zur Verfügung steht in Deutschland
ja was passiert denn am Ende 19
rauskommt das nicht
nein es ist so dass es 2000 Panzer
Leopard Panzer in Europa ich sage in
Europa gibt und ich glaube dass wenn es
2000 gibt dass dann auch die Zahl von
300 wenn das notwendig ist auch muss
hergestellt werden es ist nur einmal
natürlich auch eine Verantwortung von
Deutschland aber ich glaube wirklich als
Europäer das ist auch eine europäische
Verantwortung ist und hier muss man
zusammenstehen und nicht mit dem Finger
auf einen zeigen und dann dem die ganze
Schuld zu stellen sagt der Diplomat in
luxemburgs Regierung eine Straße geboren
ganz herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
heute Abend
bitte bitte
so und Hanna du blickst jetzt hier auf
weitere wichtige Nachrichten von heute
ja die Lage
heute überlas
teten hat sich deutlich entspannt das
erklärte der Vizepräsident der
Vereinigung der Intensivmediziner magst
Anfang des Monats lag die Zahl der
corona-patienten auf den
Intensivstationen noch bei fast 1.400
aktuell sind es 670 viele verschobene
Operationen könnten nun nachgeholt
werden
die Bundesanwaltschaft hat Anklage gegen
eine mutmaßliche Terrorgruppe erhoben
die fünf Verdächtigen sollen geplant
haben Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach zu entführen und die
Regierung zu stürzen wie die Behörde
mitteilte wird Ihnen die Gründung oder
Mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen
Vereinigung vorgeworfen sowie die
Vorbereitung eines hochverräterischen
Unternehmens gegen den Bund die vier
Angeklagten Männer waren im April 2022
festgenommen worden eine Frau im Oktober
sie befinden sich in Untersuchungshaft
der mutmaßliche Täter des tödlichen
schusswaffenangriffs auf ein Tanzlokal
nahe Los Angeles ist tot aufgefunden
worden Spezialeinheiten fanden den Mann
auf einem Parkplatz und 50 km entfernt
des Tatorts in seinem Fahrzeug laut
Polizei habe er sich dort das Leben
genommen der 72-Jährige soll am
Samstagabend in einem Tanzlokal das
Feuer eröffnet und elf Menschen
erschossen haben neuen weitere wurden
verletzt
durch die Einführung eines Tempolimits
könnten deutlich mehr Treibhausgase
eingespart werden als bisher vermutet
das halte das Umweltbundesamt heute auf
Grundlage einer neuen Studie mit bei
einer Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung von 120
Kilometern pro Stunde auf Autobahnen
bettrage das Sparpotenzial rund 6,7
Millionen Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr bisher
ging man von lediglich 2,6 Millionen
Tonnen aus
ja da bleiben wir doch noch beim Verkehr
2035 ist Schluss spätestens dann soll es
in Deutschland keine Neuwagen mit
Verbrenner mehr geben was danach kommt
ist weniger ausgemacht für die ganz
große alles umfassende Wände hin zur
Elektromobilität fehlt noch viel
Ladesäulen Reichweite und Kunden als
sowas wie die letzte Hoffnung für alle
die am Verbrenner hängen gelten
synthetische Kraftstoffe e-fuels und
Sprit auf Pflanzenbasis bei der FDP
haben diese Alternativen beim Tanken es
sogar bis ins Wahlprogramm geschafft
aber können diese Kraftstoffe halten was
sie versprechen können Sie die Zukunft
sein für viele Millionen Autos die mit
Benzin oder Dieselmotoren herumfahren
Christian hübscher ist dem nachgegangen
an dieser Tankstelle läuft ein
Experiment in Dorsten in
Nordrhein-Westfalen kann man als
Testkunde bereits 100% synthetischen
biokraftstofftanken aus Öl Abfällen der
Frittenbude zum Beispiel wird diese
glasklare Flüssigkeit gewonnen der Preis
etwa 20 Cent mehr pro Liter als für
Diesel wir glauben an an flüssige
Kraftstoffe weil wir einfach glauben
dass der Verbrennermotor vom Grundsatz
her eine Chance hat auch für die Zukunft
wir sind keine Gegner der E-Mobilität
wir sind auch keine Gegner von
Wasserstoff oder LG aber ich denke der
Weg muss sich da noch finden das
Versprechen bis zu 90% CO2 Einsparung im
Kreislauf also fast klimaneutral der
ADAC hatte den ersten Tests bestätigt
noch ist der Verkauf von rein Bio
synthetischen Kraftstoffen in
Deutschland verboten doch für den
Bundesverkehrsminister ist es eine von
vielen Optionen für den
Verbrennungsmotor von dem er nicht ganz
lassen will Wissing hier mit
Wasserstoffauto gibt sich gerne techn
nie offen synthetische Kraftstoffe
werden eine Rolle spielen man wird sie
für bestimmte Technologien brauchen wir
brauchen sie in Deutschland auch ganz
dringend beispielsweise um unseren
Flugverkehr klimaneutral zu gestalten
und wenn sie verfügbar sind macht es
Sinn sie eben auch bei Pkws einzusetzen
wissings FDP setzt auch auf eine zweite
Art synthetischer Kraftstoffe efeel
genannt aus Wasserstoff und CO2 mittels
elektrischem Strom erzeugt in diesem
Container in Karlsruhe erforschen Sie
daran Porsche und Siemens bauen in Chile
bereits ein großes Werk und tatsächlich
hätten efus Vorteile
mit den fossilen fuels vergleichen dann
ist natürlich klar dass sie weniger CO2
erzeugen im Idealfall gar keins dann ist
es die hohe Energiedichte
der Punkt dass wir keine spezielle keine
neue Infrastruktur brauchen das für die
vorhandenen Fahrzeuge die Tankstellen
all das weiter nutzen können
deckministerin PKW Massenmarkt nicht
seit Monaten schwielt der Streit
zwischen grünen und
fdpuls sind deutlich teurer in der
Herstellung die Energieeffizienz ist
geringer als bei direkter
Elektromobilität und sie sind vor allem
begrenzt und deshalb brauchen wir sie
vor allem dort wo bisher keine
Alternativen zur Verfügung stehen
beispielsweise Schiffsverkehr
Flugverkehr Schwerlastverkehr es wird
noch Jahre dauern bis synthetische
Kraftstoffe marktreif sind für
Autoexperten ist deshalb eine Rettung
des Verbrenners im großen Stil nicht in
Sicht wenn wir über synthetische
Kraftstoffe oder auch biographische
sprechen dann ist das schon zu großen
Teilen erstmal eine Phantom Debatte weil
im Moment sozusagen haben wir nicht in
den Mengen und zu den notwendigen
Preisen diese Kraftstoffe um ein
Großteil eben der Flotte der Verbrenner
zu bedienen synthetische Kraftstoffe
könnten theoretisch dabei helfen die
zwei Ziele möglichst bald zu erreichen
doch ihre Zukunft bleibt ungewiss
was Europa tut oder eben nicht tut um
das brutale Vorgehen der iranischen
Regierung gegen die Protestbewegung im
Land zu stoppen das verfolgen sie nicht
nur im Iran selbst ganz genau und zwar
sowohl bei den Demonstranten und
Demonstranten als auch im Regime der
Molas heute haben die EU-Staaten ein
viertes Sanktionspaket beschlossen es
trifft 37 Personen und Organisationen
die direkt verantwortlich gemacht werden
für die Gewalt im Iran ob Irans
revolutionsgarten als terroristische
Organisation eingestuft werden dazu gab
es allerdings keine Entscheidung dabei
ist Iran gerade mit den revolutions-
[Applaus]
das ist doch eher Tara Hussein 24
Student Sinnbild der Blutspur die Irans
Revolutionswächter im Irak hinterlassen
haben eine Kugel durch siebte seinen
Hinterkopf seitdem sind Arme und Beine
gelähmt
2019 gingen wir friedlich auf die Straße
wir demonstrierten gegen Korruptionen
Irak
tausende junge Iraker wollten einen Irak
ohne Arbeitslosigkeit ohne Korruption
ohne iranische Kontrolle doch pro
iranische Milizen finanziert von Irans
revolutionswächtern töteten hunderte
Demonstranten auch auf Taha schossen sie
heute verfolgt er jeden Protest im
Nachbarland Iran ein neuer Iran bedeutet
für ihn ein neuer Irak ein Land in dem
es endlich freie Wahlen geben kann
die iraka wir freuen uns für die Iraner
wir freuen uns über die Demonstrationen
im Iran durch die die Iraner sich
befreien wollen von diesem
diktatorischen Regime dass sie im Namen
der Religion tötet dieses regimeteran
tötete so viele iranische Demonstranten
genauso wie seine Milizen hier so viele
irakische Demonstranten töteten
der Iran kontrolliert Teile des
irakischen Staats überall wo Terran
Milizen ausbildet Waffen liefert den
Handel lenkt wünschen sich die Opfer
dieser Interventionen einen Wandel im
Iran herbei so wie barcel abuhamser
früher syrischer revolutionär aus Aleppo
jetzt Flüchtling und
journalistischer
Volk ihr Leiden ist dasselbe sie werden
beide von ein und demselben Regime
unterdrückt
Basel beobachtet wie Iran in Syrien Land
beschlagnahmt wie Iran Syrer der zu
bewegt zum schiitentum zu konvertieren
und sich Irans Milizen anzuschließen
ich habe Zeugenaussagen die belegen wie
iranische Milizen Syrer quälten und
töteten die gegen das syrische Regime
waren und zwar bis zum letzten Moment
bevor sie aus Syrien fliehen mussten das
zeigt ihren totalen konfessionellen Hass
der Mann der Tahar Hussein töten wollte
wurde nie verurteilt denn Irans Milizen
genießen Straffreiheit überall in ihren
einflussgebieten
jetzt nochmal du Hannah mit dem
traditionell an dieser Stelle
stattfindenden Blick in die Wirtschaft
ja und mit einer Meldung die den
Beschäftigten von Ford in Köln aktuell
große Sorgen bereitet der Autobauer will
dort offenbar bis zu 3.200 Stellen
abbauen erklärte heute die Vize
betriebsratschefin der Ford Werke das
wären Stellenstreichungen im großen Stil
Valerie Haller in Frankfurt wie sicher
ist das alles ja also Vater hat den
Stellenabbau nicht bestätigt war für
einen Kommentar heute aber auch nicht zu
erreichen im Moment gibt es also nur die
Aussagen von Arbeitnehmervertretern die
sich auf interne Vorgaben des
Managements Berufen ja viele Jobs
könnten tatsächlich wegfallen ganz
besonders in Köln im schlimmsten Fall
3.200 das wäre fast ein Viertel der
Belegschaft dort aber eben nicht nur da
auch in Aachen und weiteren europäischen
Standorten stehen Arbeitsplätze auf der
Kippe also große Unsicherheit bei der
Belegschaft Gewissheit soll es laut
management Frühjahr geben was weiß man
denn über die Gründe für diesen
möglichen massiven Stellenabbau ja ford
hat vergleichsweise spät auf E-Mobilität
umgestellt jetzt muss alles ganz schnell
gehen ab 2030 willfahrt nur noch
elektrische Fahrzeuge in Europa
verkaufen und die sollen dann in den USA
entwickelt werden das macht laut
Betriebsrat mehrere tausend Mitarbeiter
in Köln praktisch arbeitslos ja und
ohnehin ist der Wettbewerb in der
Autoindustrie hart für fort sind auch
die Zeiten massenhaften Autoabsatzes in
Europa schon lange vorbei das
Unternehmen will also Kosten sparen ja
und scheint da vor allem bei der
Belegschaft anzusetzen vielen Dank
Valerie für deine Einschätzung
das von der Regierung angestrebte Ziel
von 400.000 neuen Wohnungen pro Jahr ist
2022 nicht erreicht worden und wird laut
Bundesbauministerium auch 2023 verfehlt
Grund dafür seinen liefer Engpässe und
steigende Zinsen infolge des Ukraine
Kriegs dies hätte die Bedingungen
verschlechtert grundsätzlich halte man
aber an dem Wohnungsbau Ziel fest
in Berlin ist die Holocaust Überlebende
Margot Friedländer mit dem
Bundesverdienstkreuz erster Klasse
geehrt worden die 101jährige Jüdin
verlor Mutter und Bruder in Auschwitz
sie selbst überlebte das
Konzentrationslager Theresien statt bis
ins hohe Alter erzähle Friedländer in
bewundernswerter Weise aus ihrem Leben
sagte Berlins Regierende Bürgermeisterin
Giffey bei der Verleihung im Roten
Rathaus wurde zudem eine Büste
Friedländers als Ehrenbürgerin Berlins
enthüllt
[Applaus]
und jetzt zum Sport zur Handball
Weltmeisterschaft da ging es für die
deutsche Mannschaft am Abend im
polnischen Kattowitz um den gruppensiegt
gegen einen starken Gegner nämlich
Norwegen
das Endspiel um den Gruppensieg beide
bislang mit makelloser Bilanz fünf
Spiele fünf Siege Norwegen das erste
Top-Team der erste richtig dicke Brocken
für die deutsche Mannschaft Deutschland
läuft von Beginn an einem Rückstand
hinterher hat aber Yuri knorro da die
Mannschaft im Spiel hält sieben Tore
erzielt er ein Halbzeit eins
ohne darmte das 16 zu 16 erstmalig der
Ausgleich
und Andreas Wolf hält was erhalten kann
aber zu Halbzeit steht es 18 zu 16 für
Norwegen
und auch die Norweger haben einen
überragenden Torwart törburn bergerüth
dann dramatik pur nach 51 Minuten geht
Deutschland erstmalig in Thüringen
Jannik Kohlbacher 25 zu 24 am Ende sieht
die Routine Norwegen gewinnt 28 zu 26
aber die Reise geht weiter im
Viertelfinale trifft Deutschland schon
am Mittwoch in Danzig auf Olympiasieger
Frankreich
ganz live dieser Bericht geradezu mit
heißer Nadel gestrickt haben sie ein
bisschen gemerkt gut das wen hatten
trotzdem es passiert in Kneipen und am
Arbeitsplatz ist passiert millionenfach
bei Twitter und Facebook wir diskutieren
und streiten und merken dass wir beides
nicht mehr so richtig können jetzt
passiert das auch zwischen zwei
Buchdeckeln
Bestsellerautorin Juli Zeh und ihr
Kollege Simon urban haben einen Roman
geschrieben der auch sofort Diskussion
und Streit ausgelöst hat die einen
finden die täglichen Zankereien noch
öder wenn sie in erzähl pro sah
daherkommen die anderen bescheinigen dem
Buch geradezu prophetische Qualitäten
als ein Blick auf das was uns noch blöd
eine alte wg-freundschaft trifft sich
zufällig nach 20 Jahren sie mochten sich
hatten ähnliche Ziele jetzt schreiben
Sie sich per WhatsApp oder telegram und
wo bleibt die Liebe
auf der Strecke
mit viel Feuer entwickelt es sich der
neue Roman zwischen Welten von Juli Zeh
und Simon urban beide betonen sie haben
dieses Duell gemeinsam geschrieben und
das sind ihre Helden
Stefan Jordan Alter 46 Jahre Beruf
kulturchef bei der Hamburger
Wochenzeitung Boote Beziehungsstatus
ledig Name Theresa Kalles Alter 43 Beruf
Vorstand der Kuh und Co Schütte
egglücklich verheiratet zwei tolle
Kinder der kulturchef hat Meetings ein
Büro mit Blick führt Debatten über
kulturelle Aneignung und genannt die
brandenburgische Bäuerin trägt
Gummistiefel schmiert Schulbrote kämpft
mit Trockenheit und hat Frühschicht im
Kuhstall rasch setzen Sie sich über
alles mann muss das wirklich sein ich
sehe ja nur noch Sternchen vielleicht
habt ihr ja eine Direktive oder Mist zu
schreiben
nein Teresa wir haben keine Direktive so
ist der Bote nicht alle Redakteurinnen
können selbst entscheiden ich mache das
aus Überzeugung er stellt fest viele
Freunde von ihr wählen die AFD gehen da
auch ganz offen mit um einige
Angestellte von ihr tun das auch und das
ist für ihn vollkommen unvorstellbar
nicht nur ihr guter alter Freund Stefan
sondern eigentlich die ganze Elite in
den Großstädten völlig den Blick dafür
verloren hat was im Großteil des Landes
für Bedürfnisse für Ängste und für
sorgen herrschen sie Leben in zwei
Welten da herrscht schnell Wut oder
Sprachlosigkeit sie kämpft mit
Ernteausfällen hohe Pacht und einer
Wahnsinns Bürokratie für ihn den
Großstädter ist die Kuh nur ein
Klimakiller ich glaube dir fehlt einfach
der Horizont für solche Diskussionen
Ukraine
genderproblematik Klima Rassismus du
bist zu lange raus genau so geht das
sprecherposition Entziehen ich bin dann
eben einfach zu dumm um zu reden aber
eins noch Stevie besser eine Frau mit
Penis Neid als ein Waschlappen mit
heldenfantasien danke für die Lehrstunde
in Ramsch Rhetorik deine Geistes
Verwirrung kommt wahrscheinlich vom
Traktor fahren es knallt zwischen den
beiden was darf man noch sagen juli Zeh
eckt wieder einmal an in ihrem Buch geht
es um Hass und Hetze und um kenzel
es ist etwas was unserem
gesellschaftlichen Diskurs und damit der
Demokratie überhaupt nicht gut tut weil
ein Gespräch wo alle möglichst frei
sagen was sie denken ist nun mal
voraussetzung für diese Staatsform du
gehst mir den ganzen Tag mit deinem
scheiß auf die Nerven du bist echt eine
soziopatin wenn du so weiter machst hast
du bald überhaupt keine Freunde mehr nur
noch Kühe alles ist frei erfunden und
doch ist zwischen Welten ein großer
Gesellschaftsroman passt perfekt in
unsere Zeit
sagt unser Autor chris hat lepple und
das war der Montag im heute journal
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse und auch
der Hinweis auf unser heute journal up
Date Nazan göktem
Abend tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das ruhige zu Nebel neigende
Hochdruckwetter haben wir dem hochbeate
zu verdanken und dieses hochbearte
weitet seinen Wirkungskreis morgen noch
ein bisschen aus dass die jan hat ja
kräftige Schneefälle auf der alten
Südseite gebracht und zieht jetzt weiter
südwärts und dieses Tief Liam erreicht
morgen mit seinen Schnee und Regenwolken
dann Norwegen heute Nacht fällt kein
neuer Schnee bei uns es bildet sich zum
Teil etwas Nebel oder Dunst und es kann
weiterhin gefährlich glatt sein auf den
Straßen denn die Tiefsttemperaturen
liegen zwischen ein und -6 Grad am
kältesten wird es dabei am Alpen Rand
und die Höchsttemperatur morgen liegen
in den östlichen Mittelgebirge unter dem
Alpenrand um die null Grad fünf oder
sechs Grad werden es hier am Rhein oder
auch am Main und auch morgen wird
ähnlich wie heute für viele eher ein
drüber Tag sein hin und wieder kann es
ein paar mal für ein bisschen
Nieselregen etwas schnee-riese oder
einzelne Schneeflocken reichen
freundlicher sieht es aus zwischen der
Nordseeküste und der Eifel da kann sich
am Nachmittag doch mal häufiger die
Sonne zeigen der Winter zu kommt aus
nordöstlichen an der Nordsee aus
südwestlichen recht daran und ähnliches
Wetter gibt es auch am Mittwoch am
Donnerstag aber kommt dann hier von
Nordwesten Schnee und Regen heran und
dann kann es wenigstens vorübergehend
gefährlich glatt sein und Schnee fällt
dann am Freitag auch in Sachsen und in
Bayern jetzt schauen wir uns gemeinsam
noch den Trend für Dresden an da sehen
sie nämlich dass es am Samstag bei
Dauerfrost schneit danach aber lassen
die Schneefälle nach und es wird
deutlich milder guten Abend